pour le réseau dans sa globalité c'est à
150 millions de baisses en 2018 et 100
millions annoncés sur les quatre
prochaines années
l'impact pour la chambre de commerce de
la martinique ça a été un million quatre
cent mille en 2018 et neuf cent mille
euros par année jusqu'à la fin de la
mandature législatives il faudra faire
des choix alors nous serons amenés
nécessairement faire des affaires des
choix dans l'émission qui était financé
principalement par la taxe pour frais de
chambre de commerce qui finançait je le
rappelle à peu près 50% étaient affectés
à 50% environ à l'accompagnement des
entreprises dans ce dans ce chapitre
nous retrouvons à la fois le centre de
formalités des entreprises mais aussi
l'accompagnement transmission-reprise la
création tout ce qui est lié au
développement durable est donc là nous
aurons des choix stratégiques à faire
mais ces sommes étaient aussi affectées
à budget emploi formation est financée à
hauteur 2 millions 3 le centre de
formation les apprentis sur
l'apprentissage
nous avons une volonté forte de
continuer à développer ce secteur que
nous sommes engagés à monter à 900
alternants d'ici 3 4 ans et donc je
pense que nous ferons plus tôt des des
choix sûrs sur l'accompagnement des
entreprises avec une réflexion que nous
avons trop sur des prestations qui
pourrait être facturé à nos
ressortissants est là il faut un que la
loi pacte nous autorise à aller sur le
champ concurrentiel et 2 que ne soyons
pas en concurrence frontale avec nos
sorties sans parce que ça posera à terme
un problème